having that stamp of approval from
Forbes is extremely important and also
being able to be highlighted as an
entrepreneur building this is yeah it's
an absolute honor you know I've seen a
sneak peek at the other folks on the
list and don't feel like I belong here
but you know excited that a kid from
Pittsburgh out here now in San Francisco
can can get recognized and we can shine
a little bit of a broader spotlight on
the broader team and what we're trying
to do at lending home because I think
it's really great
my lovely Indian mother thinks I have a
real job which is awesome life is great
I've you know I never in a million years
that I think would be long for it oh I
just try to take it one day at a time
and you know take the blessings as they
come and um you know really just uh you
know I can be hard sometimes so when
it's great you gotta smell the roses
while it's great being a minority or a
Latino amongst group that when I was in
undergrad you would look through the
magazine always I think there's a bit of
us that always says I wish but probably
not me that emotion it's like wow like
why me but I'll do the best that I can
so many people in our age group we look
to each other right so obviously we have
mentors and role models but some of the
most brilliant people I've met are my
age and are doing these things that are
incredible and that just makes me want
to be you know a better person or a
better leader a better entrepreneur so I
just I love being able to be associated
with such an awesome group of folks who
are you know the next generation and
then this country's future so I think
that's that's the really exciting and
amazing thing it means everything it
means that my mom is sitting at home
right now waiting for a call from me to
tell her how my shoot went like she's
really proud
you